it's because of drugs
no
crack is wack
diane's infamous whitney interview
katie's quoted calling it exploitation
of troubled people in service of tawdry
tidbits and sensational sound bites what
risk did you think you were taking to do
this the woman who had twins at 57 katie
jokingly writes i wonder who she had to
blank to get that 2
808 everyone shows
that woman must be stopped and i loved
that i was getting under diane's skin
that's from katie's memoir going there
out this month and exerted by the new
york post sawyer hasn't commented but
once told us this about her rival we're
all family in the morning across
networks we are and we all know what it
is to be able to do it as well as she
has done it all these years however in
the book curt claims both women weren't
above flattering whoever stood in the
way of a big get well the truth is
what we are all striving for
yeah
it is between this and katie's matt
lauer revelation some morning show fans
are now convinced jennifer aniston's
character is based on couric have you
been able to stay in touch with matt i
mean that's kind of a personal matter
i'm not interested in talking about
mitch you came to see me
like katie jen reaches out after his
sexual misconduct firing and even writes
a memoir about it i'll go back
and look at the manuscript i think
jennifer aniston is is great i thought
it was really interesting to watch last
year on the podcast everything iconic
with danny pellegrino katie teased she'd
be detailing her feelings about the
morning show in this memoir i think the
long-term impact and the serious
devastation that results from certain
behaviors was quite well represented
[Music]